One of the things I really
love about being a developer
is that it's this
constant churn of puzzles.
You're constantly trying
to solve a new thing
or fit new pieces
into a box that
won't allow them to fit there.
For the analytical mind, it's
just this amazing playground
that you can just run as
far as you want to in it.
And what's really great about
that is that it's not just
about solving these problems
and putting them together,
but it's also about having the
ability to influence people,
and make apps for people, and
change the way people's lives
work, while also still
getting a chance to solve
these puzzles every day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]